[Music]
[Applause]
okay this of course is a segment where
viewers are try to find mistakes on our
show all right we invite them to try and
find mistakes on our show that's the
part that I think is brave we dare
people find a mistake all right so far
in the last five years hundreds of
challengers not one winner we don't make
them nope
a flawless show well tonight a fan named
Brian killin says he thinks he caught a
mistake he says it happened during a
recent monologue joke about the Chinese
financial crisis hey what's going on
Conan I'm just watching your show
actually right now after work
just saw that you said that Jackie Chan
will be making rush hour 5 through 10
yesterday China's stock market crashed
causing many of its richest citizens to
lose millions yeah in a related story
Jackie Chan just signed on for rush
hours 5 through 10 but there actually
was never a rush hour for so as much as
I love you and love you and Andy day I
got you on this one oh you think he's
got me do you you're on his side I want
to I would go after Brian but I don't
want to he seems to press
that's a tough day at work Sun wind it
with us
yeah I don't know I'm worried about the
guy cheer up Brian it's all gonna be
fine
but I gotta tell you you are dead wrong
I'm sorry Brian you were just wrong on
this one we did not make a mistake they
did make a rush hour for you just missed
it because it was only released in China
here's a clip control metonymy - aw yeah
wait your cops on you man - aw you don't
what then do you eat here water and
total of hunger Paul Scheer ones you
want them show me - are you like older
than toad
great you cops on you man - sorry it was
earlier drinking there was a thousand
tongue condiment songs about new agent
you won them so we know
[Applause]
Wow alright maybe that'll cheer him up
to know that he was in a movie quits
Benson's in a big movie yeah
anyway the challenge still stands if you
think you've sported an era on our show
reported at Team koco.com slash haha I
found an error we will sort it out right
here on the air let's see if you have
what it takes to make chunk meat out of
the maestro we'll take a little break
coming back
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography